we're wrapping up 2019 2019 has been an
interesting year in many ways and one of
those ways has been one of one of the
ways that we've seen the insanity of
2019 has been through the total fake nan
controversies that have been promoted by
the American right-wing office and
service too distracting from something
actually horrible that Donald Trump has
done and Media Matters put together a
very good list of what they are calling
non traverses non controversies in 2019
that have appeared on Fox News and I
want to remind you about a couple of
them and before we do it we do have real
scandals happening in real stories we
have protests for democracy and rights
in many places around the world we've
seen an explosion of extremist white
nationalism the president has been
impeached we've had more than a mass
shooting a day for the entire year the
United States President is a
laughingstock around the world on and on
and on but on Fox News check out some of
the things that were scandals the
Gillette razor ad which was directed at
men in the me2 era showing bullying and
sexism and saying hey men you should
behave Fox News went nuts saying it
attacks men we saw the James Bond
controversy actors Daniel Craig and
Pierce Brosnan who have played James
Bond historically saying they would be
supportive of a female double-oh-seven
like lashana Lynch who will be cast as
double-oh-seven in an upcoming movie and
there was outrage how the political
correctness of a fake James Bond how
could James Bond be a woman chick-fil-a
of course chick-fil-a saying in 2019
they will no longer donate to anti LGBTQ
organizations Fox News said this was
chick-fil-a crumbling and bowing to
left-wing attacks we saw a lot of mass
shootings in 2019 two big ones were in
Texas and Ohio and after those Universal
Pictures said we're not going to publish
our movie the hunt which depicts
deplorable 'he's being hunted by elite
liberals as they couched it because it
was in horrible taste given the mass
shooting
problem that we have and Fox said this
is evidence of the hypocritical left
they want division they want to go after
Trump voters but they also say they are
against gun violence what a scandal in
2019 Fox News talked about a war on
Thanksgiving check this out
here is a summary from Media Matters
we've heard about the war on Christmas
but now college students are declaring a
war on Thanksgiving forget the war on
Christmas the left is now going after
Thanksgiving this is pizzas the war on
Thanksgiving do they want to fight a war
on Thanksgiving they lost the war on
Christmas they want to fight again PC
police will they have a new target
Thanksgiving cancelled culture has
turned on the holiday cancel
Thanksgiving dinner very sad to announce
we have to cancel Thanksgiving all
across America a growing number of
students and professors claim we need to
throw air turkeys no Turkey no traveling
cranberry sauce and mashed potatoes are
bad for the planet Trump also saying at
a rally that the left wants to not call
it Thanksgiving all of this apparently
was catalyzed by an article in
Huffington Post called the environmental
impact of your Thanksgiving dinner Wow
clearly a call to cancel Thanksgiving
what a scandal and then of course
there's always the war on Christmas the
war on Christmas is always a scandal
year in and year out on Fox News among
other enclaves of the right if they put
as much energy into fixing real problems
rather than creating new ones think
about how much better off we would be
imagine if Fox News instead of
propagandizing or about a Gillette ad
said hey we have hunger in this country
and it's optional we could decide at any
time we are not going to have hunger
anymore we're not gonna have people go
hungry we could fix that now instead
they've got to do the Gillette ad
imagine if they said medical bankruptcy
must end it's time for us to join the
fight for a solution instead of being
part of the problem now
instead it's liberals want to cancel
Thanksgiving and of course the real big
meta scandal at Fox News a spark
News continuing to carry water for an
unhinged liar of a president while
perpetuating baseless conspiracies and
pretending conspiracy theories better
said and pretending to be a new station
rather than opinion that is not going to
change in 2020
the only question is are they fully with
Trump or not and we will see as we get
into 2020